[Music]
welcome to the Samuel Leeds podcast my
name is Amelia and part of the marketing
team and in this episode we'll be
talking entrepreneurship is it for
everyone
is it a skill that can be learned and
how Samuel mastered the art hello how
are you I'm awesome Amelia I love
talking with you how has your day been
what have you been up to
you know what I've actually had a pretty
chill day so I've been I've been a play
centre with my wife and kids hanging out
drinking coffee eating chocolate is that
your normal day well I I don't really
have a normal day I think especially
when it comes to seeing my family and
hanging with the kids and stuff I know a
lot of people have a lot of my friends
entrepreneur friends I've set time for
that so Oh on a Saturday that's family
day or this time to this time when's
that but for me it's just spontaneous as
and when it happens which it happens
quite a lot yeah so is that what's just
like a day-to-day look like for you in
terms of you don't have routine but do
you work a lot
do you work weekends are you oh man yeah
I mean I don't have routine I do have
certain set things I do every day like
but but but generally speaking every day
is really different and I could be
viewing houses I could be on the phone I
could be doing training programs I could
be in the office meeting with staff
directors meeting meeting with accounts
list as lawyers brokers it's just super
varied but always focused on you know um
growing the business I'm growing myself
yeah on helping people with their
property journey so it's kind of focus
focused but just very varied yeah has it
changed a lot over the past like three
four years I think yeah as I've done
more training
so I started I run the first training my
first training program in November 2014
and that was like almost a bit of a I
thought it was gonna be a one-off now I
do quite a bit of training a lot of
speaking travelling so yeah and and now
I've got a little you know the business
has all staff so it's it's quite
different than it was four years ago
just ever-evolving yeah yeah and because
obviously like Russell's
the CEO company now did you find that
kind of how did you find that experience
of putting like your brother a CEO like
did you want to hold on to the title of
CEO or you know what I am so unbothered
by titles you delegate a lot which is
good yeah but tied to a title doesn't
mean anything you know you can have you
have a and I think part of going to
Bible College and being you know
training within the church background a
lot of people there was a lot of people
that were like aspiring to be a pastor
or aspiring to be an elder or you know a
position within the church and it's the
same with in companies people I want to
be a manager you know I want to be I
want to director I want to be if you
want a title just like you anyway so if
you want to just just act like it anyway
and the title comes I'm really not
bothered about titles I'm more bothered
about just inspiring my team inspiring
people leading from and I hope this is
the case I don't think it's I think it's
always the case but I try and lead from
example and and and you know I'll say to
my staff and hopefully York and Kay as a
member of the team but yeah how can I I
help you
so rather than just sort of seeing teeny
blurs are you work for me actually no I
work I work for I work for my staff and
my job is to make their lives as easy as
possible to train them to inspire them
to equip them so no it wasn't difficult
given away the CEO tile but even even
pop the business long
my brother Russell he's a business
partner yeah because I'd rather have I'd
rather have 50% of something much bigger
and impact way more people than 100% of
something smaller and impact less people
so again it's not about titles it's not
about being the boss it's just it's just
about impact quite big on everyone being
intrapreneurial yes yes so you can't
pick on everyone kind of in the company
innovating and stuff like that is it's
not something you kind of have a look
for in people that they're kind of
innovating within and making the company
their own yeah so basically definition
of an intrapreneur according to Samuel
Leeds is delivers a turn this use a lot
but is an entrepreneur but from within a
company
so most most entrepreneurs fail
statistically 80 percent of biz
says fail and the other 20% that
apparently succeed they don't succeed
because most of them don't make any
money anyway they just don't get closed
down so so to be an entrepreneur is
lonely is risky is hard it's high
pressure so what I'm looking for is to
find people who are natural born
entrepreneurs leaders innovators inspire
us and then have them with inside the
company so they then they become
intrapreneurs and they bring their
skillset their creativity their passion
their drive their ambition inside so I
don't I don't even I don't even see I
don't even see the people within within
my company as people like employees yeah
or even people with jobs they're
intrapreneurs with with that a part of
the mission and I think that's the way
it is I think that's the way that people
people see anything if someone in within
the company doesn't like if someone sees
a job and doesn't like it we'll just ask
them to leave we just will you enjoy and
I think that's why we even switch people
over from customer service due to
training advisors to this to that
because we want people to be operating
within their values do what they love
you know so yeah that's something I'm as
a business owner and as a leader I'm
really really passionate about yes so
when you're kind of looking for people
what are what would you say the
characteristics are of an entrepreneur
like what is it that you're kind of
looking for someone that's a problem
solver okay so someone who is anyone
that solving problems is really an
entrepreneur because most people either
avoid problems yeah or find problems you
know they'll focus in on the problem
whereas I want to be someone and
surrounded by people who are instead of
doing that who are constantly finding
solutions oh there's a problem here
we've got this issue you know we haven't
got a big enough venue or this property
we can't get planning permission for
this property okay how can we get around
this who can we speak to you who can we
I think that's the definition of an
entrepreneur so what do you think the
characteristics are like what are you
looking for when you're gonna employ
someone what are their entrepreneurial
characteristics that you're looking for
I think attitude is more important than
skill so if someone's got really good
skills but they've got
all gratitude yeah they don't love the
company they don't love what they're
doing then in my opinion in my book that
would not be someone that I would want
to hire if they've got a great attitude
and they're coachable and they've got
good energy about them yeah and their
skills are average built with potential
to be good and I'd much rather hire that
person so I think it's just people
people that actually are passionate have
good energy have a good attitude and are
competent people of course you know
they're coachable they can I'd much
rather that then take someone who's like
good but arrogant
or you know so I just think attitude is
always more important skill yeah because
we're quite a different company like
even in the mornings will be there
dancing yeah very different in like
sharing like what successes from the day
before
yeah and that's and even our events I
try and events we dance Sibelius I why
do you dance are so stupid well look at
the results we get yeah you know look at
the results we get because if you if you
spend two minutes in the morning just
having a stretch having a dance or
moving the body around then your brains
more active so you know we don't do
anything we don't do anything without
studying it and doing it for a reason
but yeah we do dance and if and again if
people are like role in their eyes and
this never happens yeah but if we had
staff that obviously stupid I don't want
to dance so I don't want to stretch then
you know it's just just have some fun
big energy means big results yeah and
have fun while you working and enjoy
what you're doing because I know I'm
enjoying what I'm doing and I'll be
damned if I know that people are working
within the company that I hate in it
yeah you know so there's no perfect
business there's no perfect system
there's no perfect company we're
certainly not perfect on certain are
perfect but that's that's certainly what
I believe in terms of like
entrepreneurial like qualities and being
like an entrepreneur at work what do you
think it is that makes somebody what
characteristics you have someone
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial someone
that's not thinking like a nine to fiver
if you're watching the clock thinking at
five o'clock I'm out of here
that's not an entrepreneur that's not an
intrapreneur that's that's an employee
mindset whereas if you think in I don't
work nine to five I work start to finish
I just get
I'm thinking about the results I'm
thinking about the tasks and I'm owning
it I think that that's what that's what
entrepreneur is and you know we talked
about this in intrapreneurs intrapreneur
something meaning someone who is
entrepreneurial like a problem solver
but working from within an organization
so yeah I mean there's just some of the
things we look for so do you think that
anybody can be an entrepreneur do you
think it's something that you can
develop no I don't think anyone can be
an entrepreneur depends on entrepreneur
like well what do you think what do you
believe in entrepreneur is an
entrepreneur is someone that takes risks
in the hope to make money an
entrepreneur is someone who is a
creative risk-taking go-getting person
yeah that in hope to help people to make
money I mean can anyone be an
entrepreneur I guess it depends on what
level like statistically most business
people fail yeah you know so I guess
it's difficult I guess anyone can try I
mean entrepreneur cannot be successful I
guess without the correct training
without the support without the without
the desire without the imprinted natural
burning desire to do it I mean I don't
know
yeah I'm born to be an entrepreneur born
to be a business a business person yeah
whether I believe that anyone can be
financially free now financially free
meaning that you've got some form of
passive income covering you're covering
your outgoings your bells mini work is a
choice I believe that anyone can do that
because you can do that by working
really hard at a job saving up learning
to invest that money over a period of
time anyone can do that whether you can
run a company
and-and-and-and be in the media and have
staff and and deal with that and cope
with that pressure yeah I don't think
it's for everybody so do you see it more
as inma you're kind of drawn to be an
entrepreneur
though you think you were always gonna
be an entrepreneur probably yeah
probably I mean everybody has everybody
is born with the desire to do something
some people had dissolved Warren with a
desire to want to be dancers or singers
or performers or investors or I was born
with a desire to
business and help people and when I say
help people it's because and and the
some people think there's like almost
like oh but I run a business to make
lots of money but I do help people too
as if the to a contrary but actually if
you're running a successful business by
definition you're helping a lot of
people yeah
because a lot Albert Einstein says don't
try and be successful trying to be
valuable the only way you'll become
successful is by being valuable okay so
you gotta you've gotta think as an
entrepreneur how can I help people how
can I solve problems how can I add value
to people how can i how can I find ways
to give people what they want and then
in doing that then you create a product
or service yeah around that so I think
that's why I talk about helping people
because it's not about as a business as
a businessman I'm not constantly looking
at my bank balance constantly trying to
get more money constant tryna I'm not
trying to do that I'm trying to help
more people I'm trying to find more
people that need to sell their houses
because they're in a pickle and then I'm
gonna solve that problem and then I'm
gonna turn it into luxury accommodation
I'm gonna find a tenant that loves to
live there my tenants am a customer you
want I'm training people I'm not trying
I'm not trying how many how much money
can I get from my mentees now I'm trying
to think how many people can I help
become financially free as well because
I know that the more ultimately with
every avenue of business the more people
you're helping is them all people well
then want to do business with you in the
bigger business will grow yeah
definitely so would you say for example
and Luke yellowboy is do you think you
could potentially make him into like say
now if you were gonna be like I'm gonna
make him the most successful
entrepreneur in the world
yeah do you think that is something you
can kind of help towards or do you think
it is like completely an A if he didn't
want to do it he wouldn't do it and that
at the end of its or things I think I
could teach him to be a fantastic
investor who knows all the ins and outs
of investments and he can he can make a
shrewd decision I think I can help help
make him a world-class chess player or
badminton player yeah an entrepreneur
there's so many aspects to it to run a
large business I think you've for him to
do that he needs to have the fire to
wanna do that in the desire so I don't
think I could
I think if I said right Luke's gonna be
a really successful entrepreneur and
main loads and loads of money I don't
think that's within my control or power
I think that's done to him would you
could you not see yourself doing
anything else in terms of not a
businessman an entrepreneur yeah I could
I fancy myself his money is my deep deep
dark secret as a rapper
no although I have rats in the past yeah
do you like you've rap for me no ever oh
okay I really see myself doing movies
I'd love to do movies yeah so uh and
again nothing to do like business or my
I just I just I just really enjoy it and
I love watching movies and I just really
enjoy I could movie and someone who's
backed it apart Wow I just yeah I think
you're an actor and a producer actor
actor maybe even maybe even part of the
production you know the screenwriting
yeah I love him because I think it fits
with part of the it wouldn't be a boring
movie it wouldn't be a movie that was
around like something it'll be a movie
that would have to inspire or it kind of
fits with the reason I put out YouTube
videos and this podcast is ultimately to
only educate people or to inspire them
yeah and I think music and movies and
arts generally it can be a way to really
and I know I've been really inspired and
impacted and help my music and movies
and and that's something that I would
like to be part of but whether I have
the the skills or the opportunities will
say you can bar the market and see if
you want money so if so you kind of
don't you don't think it's an innate
thing but in terms of letting people get
that point in their life where they're
being the most successful they can at
what they have the desire to do yeah do
you have any kind of tips that you would
give people like what advice would you
give to someone if they were just
wanting to be successful yeah in what
they do
okay firstly well I just want to say
there's a big difference between what
I'm talking about about being you're
like an entrepreneur I'm talking about
someone that wants to go and make
millions of pounds have loads of staff
we're in a really big enterprise that's
kind of what I'm talking about when I'm
saying you gotta have a deep
desire because there's gonna be a lot of
crap you have to go through to get to
that so that's one thing another thing
is just having a side business or you
know getting some properties or getting
or getting some prop but you know saving
up money properly or do some joint
ventures and getting some properties or
getting a couple of rent event deals to
give you some freedom in your life extra
time that is a different thing
yeah and that's more I think what I
teach certainly in the early days and
then people that become financially free
some of them have got the desire in the
burn and then over like hey you need a
mission you need to submit that grips
you in but but I think that's a
different thing so what advice would I
give give I think firstly it's a case of
there's you to be a very serious
entrepreneur you've got to have the fire
in your belly you've got to have the
burn some people have the fire in the
belly to have the burn but then people
dampen air and because of fear and lack
of support and lack of training it
doesn't come to anything yes and then
and then these people they know on their
you know in their retirement saying I
wish I wish I'd done this I could have
done this I had the capability to do
this yeah but you didn't because you
chickened out so I don't say is if
you've got the fire then just do it and
and get the support and take the risk if
you haven't got the fire and you don't
want to do it though that's fine
you know if you're happy to just make
two grand a month even if it's passive
income and I said to some other students
sometimes people will build up two or
three grand a month passive income
passive meaning not from a job that I
have to work anymore
and then they were armed I'm just go
stay at home now and do that trap in
hand I'm like listen if you want to do
that that's totally cool that's fine
life is choices but for me I wouldn't be
satisfied with that so I I just think
figure out what you want you dream
really big be unashamed of have how
outlandish the goals are because most
people's problems is not they hit their
that there's a sack got nobody said if
it's all said it's not that people the
people's problems is not that their goal
is too high and they miss it is that
it's too low and they hit it yeah so
make you goal the thing that's in your
heart and in your burning in you and you
soul write it down and then go to town
and make it
yeah because I'm whether that's working
sorry whether that's working within a
company whether that's doing your own
thing whether that's doing something
that's not business related or whether
that's being a Hollywood movie actor
whether that's been a politician with us
being a teacher well there's been a
missionary whatever yeah just don't do
it make you happen golden advice do you
think that the minute because there is a
lot of people these days that want to
have their own businesses even if it's
just like a side hustle do you think
entrepreneurship is something that's
become trendy and a bit kind of
glamorized glamorized I definitely think
that it's kind of in and kind of trendy
but if you see as a side hustle if you
think arms can have a little bit of a go
on the side and do a bit I mean
depending on what it is you might end up
if you do it because it's cool you know
I it's cool and I watched a few Gary
Vaynerchuk videos and and and then
you're gonna if you do it as a site also
you're gonna get a side hustle results
yeah so ultimately it's going to decide
what you want to make it happen yeah and
in terms of like the future of
entrepreneurship do you think that it's
going to increasingly become something
that we're seeing people open your
businesses after after because jobs are
becoming less and less earned and hard
and harder to get yeah really hard to
get so especially if you're a bit older
like if you're thirty four is if you're
in your 20s it's not so bad if you're in
your 40s or 50s getting the job is near
impossible for some people so I think
that as jobs become systemized so
there's a lot of like for instance
everything's becoming all systemize like
you go to Sainsbury's now and you don't
need a cashier Yeah right so what's
happening is more and more people are
losing their jobs but then I tell you
what's happening though is innovators
are having to create the systems so
someone's someone's making money yeah
the cashier is not but someone's making
money somewhere who is it well it's the
person that's being innovative that's
coming up with these systems and so I
think entrepreneurship is going to
become more and more of a thing I think
as people get less and less satisfied
with jobs yeah I think people are going
to be four
most into entrepreneurship and it's
gonna yeah 100%
yeah skills yeah true and there's no
training for it really it's hard you
can't you can't learn to be an
entrepreneurial University you can get
business you you can go and get business
some you know business qualifications
but I've done this sort of stuff I've
you know I got NVQ level three Business
Studies and then I went on a Jim roses
sell off education will make your
fortune but but formal education will
make you a living so yeah I mean I'm not
meaning to bash anything but a lot of
these accredited business schools are
taught by people who've never run a
business yeah or failed you found that
yeah yeah no I did a digital media a uni
and then I did a entrepreneurship like
module to call it yeah and yeah it was
taught by someone who had never had a
business she spoke about three years
older than me I couldn't believe it
right honestly couldn't buy I mean the
other people who've come through
marketing jobs and they've got first
honours degrees in marketing spent five
years studying marketing spent fifty
thousand pounds in student debt to do
marketing they come for an interview and
they I've got the first clue about
marketing they don't know what a CRM
system is they don't know how to run a
Facebook ad all the basic stuff that
businesses need the basics of marketing
they're gonna go yeah they know all
about this pompous stuff but stuff that
I certainly don't know anything about
but the stuff that I need and most
business medium small businesses need
yes I'm just I'm just wondering what
they even teach yeah I might I might go
to university to study marketing just to
find out what they teach me for a laugh
Samuel Leeds goes back to uni maybe I
did it before yeah I do it before I went
to Bible College after became
financially free pretty much yeah
I'm not bashing uni okay yeah and people
get so up as I put posters up on
Instagram or whatever and I've mentioned
about how uni can be misleading and
stuff of that and people go crazy yeah
and I think the reason people get so
offended is because
them or their children have invested so
much time resources of money into it
they're almost sensitive and they're
like don't bash that that's I spent in a
long time don't take this away from me
but I'm not here to be liked I'm here to
speak truth and the truth is unless
you're going to university because you
need to get a particular qualification
or skill set that's going to give you
the live job dream whatever you want if
you go just because oh well that's what
you do isn't it you go to university if
you go with just study art just because
I quite like art but you've got no
reason whatever it's probably going to
be a very big waste of time money and
energy
yeah I agree for four years right four
years and what do you think what you
told me you think it's a scam yeah I
just think it's hard because you knees
always more than just in a classroom
it's not the people that you're meeting
like for example I went on a study
abroad to Australia so obviously I got
that opportunity that I wouldn't
probably have and there's a lot to uni
but knowing what I know now would I
still go to uni I don't think so
you don't think so you definitely
wouldn't it's hard because I I came from
a village so for me it was quite a big
eye-opener meeting people from all
around the world at uni and I know I
could have done that if I'd have just
like for example moved to London I'll
move to a big city I think it was a
stepping stone yeah I do think was a
stepping stone before did the degree
help you know would you have a lot more
spending three days with me Yeah right
probably about marketing probably would
of yeah I'm not about life or about fur
I'm sure you learn loads of things over
the four years I'm not trying to be like
yo dismissive of the four years but like
actually hands-on stuff yeah that's the
pro of working for a company that's kind
of still like a small scale yeah in its
some degree and like yeah everyone just
pitches in and like even yesterday when
we were having like a meeting with you
and going through marketing I love that
and I mean hopefully as well I was
talking earlier about how you know how
we are as a company and how I lead and
like on stuff is it true ringing true
yeah I hope you still feel that way in
six months
we'll see we'll say do you think that in
the future they'll be more well she's
like more ways that like people won't go
down the modern education route people
will look for more things like for
example the training that you offer and
you know training for other things that
they want to get involved in rather than
going down the traditional model I mean
I don't know for sure but I think that I
just now we've got social media and
everything's in the light right so back
in the day nothing's in the light but I
think that University is failing so many
people and there's more and more people
see that yeah and I finish uni and then
they can't get a job but they were led
to believe that it'll be easy to get a
job with that art degree but now it's
like oh actually we can't and I still
think the old mindset of you know oh
well it's if people say to my
sister-in-law okay she I've managed to
persuade her to sign up for some of our
advanced training and she's coming on it
but the day of our training she's got an
exam at uni and she's like oh and she's
and she's trying to work out what to do
I'm like don't even take the exam forget
it because she knows okay she's almost
finished in you know she's like a like
six months off but she knows that the
thing that she's studying she doesn't
want to do yeah I don't want to do that
she doesn't wanna do it she doesn't want
to get a job she wants to finish you
know and then she wants to go become a
property entrepreneur okay so she
doesn't 100% does not want to get a job
she does not want to get a job in the
thing that she's studying either so I'm
like what's the point of finished in
yeah what's the point all because it's
like a safety option you know it's like
a good plan based solid for me I just
think I don't see it that way so
everyone's different there's no right or
wrong but I do think that probably in 20
years time and and I just read this
morning that two-thirds of students that
get student debt
never pay back died with the debt to
that yeah
they never earn enough money to pay it
back right but that just shows that the
system is so flawed to me I know it's
complex yeah I know it's complex but
and there's no right or wrong but for me
I think that uh I think they will become
less popular at the moment it's just a
done thing in people's minds it's get
good grades then go to university then
get a good job for life and then save up
money and then put that money in the
bank and then buy a house when you're in
your forties and then and then retire
and live what that's that's the
old-school way of thinking and I
personally think it's completely
fundamentally flawed because there's no
such thing is a good job for life that
it isn't so
if you just go get it's it's not safe
yeah the average person's twenty-one
jobs now I'm trying to make that
different I think it's different in our
company but the average person has 21
jobs from the ages between 20 and 35 21
jobs okay you need doesn't even
guarantee a job there's so many people
that finish University and can't get a
job so I just think this is the
statistics speak for themselves
yeah it's so true even so like some of
my friends they might have gone to uni
and an English or history and when they
come out and then people be like oh you
went to you needed media which I still
wish I kind of didn't do but then
they'll come out of uni and they'll once
go into a media job and I'm like say why
did you spend three years doing English
for example and they'll be like oh well
you know it's just a done thing when dad
said right it's just crazy
study history great well that doesn't
help you in our business yeah unless
you're gonna be a historian like TV
presenter talking about history ah yeah
I think it helps though with because a
lot of employers still have the old
mindset
maybe because some like of they're like
CEOs and people your world are slightly
older yeah I think with a lot of like
new entrepreneurs and people like you
that slightly younger you're employing
on a different basis totally different
based on degree that's becoming more
more common yeah less and less employers
give a rip about university
qualifications and degrees they don't
care what people care about is what
value can you bring to my company that's
what people that I hate you know
there'll be people that hanging on this
podcast
oh my gosh how dare you slam university
you don't know what you're talking about
it's really important listen I'm an
employer and I know a law
of employers you know big businesses
small business medium businesses and I'm
telling you this less and less people
employers give a rip about your
university qualifications what they care
about is and it all comes down to this
which is value how much value can you
bring to our company into our customers
if you if you can just say if you spent
four years instead of at university
thinking I want to be more valuable how
can I become what skills do I need to be
valuable in the marketplace and how can
I go get those skills you can be much
richer definitely if you could go back
10 years what would you tell yourself I
do what I did really you still do is I
thought you didn't it II much exactly
what I mean Bible College was kind of
just from a position of I can write
because when I went to Bible College I
was 20 years old I had a handful of
handful of properties li'l portfolios
giving me a full-time income so I the
choice to go and it was more of a
personal personal thing yeah I didn't do
for business reasons but if I was going
about ten years I did the same thing I
mean I mean 10 years ago I was just
before when I was nineteen eighteen ten
years ago I would just invest in myself
I'd become valuable I would work for
free yeah for people like landlords and
agents and investors to get the
information I don't get good I'll get
good at sales
I'll get good investments I'll get
understand money I want to go to
university why to get a job why to make
money we'll just learn about money
skip the skip the Uni stuff study money
and we teach this to us though we did
you see you guys you know our staff yeah
here's how you manage money here's and
this stuff on selling the stuff I'm
telling my audience is the same stuff I
tell my staff you know get valuable get
valuable make money and we give
opportunities for people within our
company to make a lot of money so get
valuable make money make more than you
need and then the extra put it aside
and invest it and then build up slowly
your passive income until your passive
income succeeds your living expenses
which means you're financially free and
then at that point work from a position
of abundance and you'll probably work
harder than you ever thought you would
because when you're working out of
choice rather than out of having to do
it suddenly something awakens inside of
you and you work from a mission Purpose
Driven
which is a beautiful thing which is what
I do and there's like I know back like
ten years ago you would have had a lot
of different challenges than what you
have today so back then for example you
might have a challenges like if you were
juggling uni alongside your business and
things like that what what do you think
challenges you now because some people
think Oh Sam you're Leeds you've got it
all
so like popular now and you know you've
got your brand you've got your business
that's doing so well so what challenges
do you face now okay so my challenge is
back then was I don't have enough money
yeah and I don't have money
I'm skin um I've invested everything
into my education I've invested every
last penny and more into property and
actually right now although I've got
money tied up in property I'm at the
petrol station with my little car with
my card there's no money on it which is
declining and I'm stranded and it's
raining and I'm needing to phone my
little sister and ask her if I can
borrow fifty quid just to top my car
being at home like that's that's that
that's the kind of problems that I had
back then working crazy hours being told
you won't do it you won't succeed
it's risky you're too young it's a pipe
dream but people that were close to me
yeah that was my problems now now I have
whole host of different ones very very
different but I have stronger problems
bigger problems like I think it's hard
to say exactly but I'd say probably
right now today my biggest problem is
training people to be as good as me
but in their own area so you know
training people trying our training
advisers to be able to speak to people
and explain properly and training our
customer service team to respond to
messages and training like I'm kind of
like a trainer from within the company
and and just fart is funded by people
just getting good people and and I think
that that's today a big challenge but a
man I have problems everyone else bombs
yeah
like what do you want specifically your
company like how do you want it to be
different mm-hmm than other companies
like the traditional company like is
there anything you want yeah I want
almost all I want a company the freedom
formula to not only bring people freedom
but also I want our whole company and
our staff to be working have freedom to
work so have freedom to be innovative
you know the the team to be able to
think outside the box take risks this is
something I even said to you guys I
might push the batter's take risks I'd
rather I'd rather have to tell you man
you messed up what were you thinking
doing that outrageous marketing stunt
like I'd rather have to have that
conversation than be like guys man
you're too vanilla yeah you know so
freedom to just to just be a bit crazy
freedom to think outside the box freedom
to yeah I think I think it's from it's
all about freedom teaching freedom
bringing freedom to people and and and
everywhere I go having a bubble of
freedom around me that spreads you know
so I think that that's what I want to
differentiate myself from other
companies and people yeah it's so true
like in the meeting the other day like
we were talking about like financial
freedom and we've all settled for six
bank accounts we did that the other day
or some loved that yeah so it's it's it
kind of I always think it trickles down
from like their CEO founder like yes the
culture kind of trickles down and
everyone it's kind of what would you
call it like everyone just have it you
just absorbed the energy and I think
when people first come to this company
that just kind of shocked at first cuz
they they just can't believe that energy
like today we Sarah had was running
around the office with a daughter it was
just incredible yeah this morning yeah
that's so cool no you're right I love I
love the company I love the people and
my my best friends are definitely people
that I work with how is it being friends
with other people that are entrepreneurs
or entrepreneurial because I know a lot
of your friends are either like in the
business or friends who have other
businesses yeah how do you kind of find
those relationships right yeah I mean I
get entrepreneurs I get people that
think business minded I don't understand
I don't understand people
I don't understand people I can't be
around people that negative that
complain the how you doing today
fine I'll feel good Friday one step
closer to the weekend I didn't get that
and I can't be around that so people
that have running businesses or people
that are intrapreneurs within businesses
I think it's just great
so I was gonna say is there any kind of
misconceptions of entrepreneurship
because a lot of people are finding like
when I talk to friends and stuff
everyone's like I need to get out my job
you know I can have this laptop
lifestyle yeah and I know we kind of
touched on it before but I feel like I
feel like it is becoming such a big
trend like I think majority of my
friends want to come out of their jobs
yeah if they ever had them when you do
it's a hard one it's a hard one for me
to even say because some people will say
oh my gosh it's too risky don't do it
it's impossible and I would say they're
wrong but then other people will have
this fantasy that they can quit their
job and then it can just set up some
automated online system online and I've
passive income and then never work again
which is a fantasy you know so I think
somewhere in the middle there's the
truth which is that you can you can quit
your job and you can be an entrepreneur
and you can make full-time income
passive income 100% but if you want to
be a doctor you've got to get trained
it's it's it's hard work you've got to
get the skills you can't just go you
know what I'm gonna be a doctor
and then start doing surgery tomorrow
otherwise we'd be in trouble and in the
same way running a business or being an
entrepreneur it does take skill
it just takes skill so and you can
either do that by learning on the job
which could take five or ten years yeah
or get a mentor or attend the class
isn't the same you know that's why we
run training programs because I think if
you get the skills and put in the time
and and and approach do whatever it
takes
it's possible but it nothing nothing
comes without sacrifice yeah and nothing
comes without risk so property investing
is risky but anything is risky crossing
the street is risky driving is risky
putting money in the bank is risky very
risky so it's about eliminating those
risks as far as you can with education
and they're making an informed decision
do you think you took big risks massive
risks yeah but then I didn't have
anything to lose anyway
yeah just a kid yeah did you sacrifice a
lot I sacrificed a lot yeah sacrifice
friendships yeah I don't have a
girlfriend I don't have a girlfriend
from from the age of 16 16 to 22 I was
single
you know for someone who's really
good-looking he keeps having girls yeah
I knew that was coming no but in all
seriousness you know I was single I
didn't have a social life particularly I
didn't I was just working yeah so and
that's the reality and I don't like bang
on about that but that's just the
reality of it the education and the
training animals getting and then people
say oh you just got look at it yeah look
yeah that's really hard
I've got good training programs I got
good support network I put myself in the
right time at the right place yeah and
do you find because I know you've had a
few businesses so do you find that even
now you're kind of have ideas for
different businesses and things like
that and do you have to kind of keep
your focus on your business all the time
yeah all the time
I have so many ideas and the thing is if
I do you write them down I just I think
the ideas I just I just I might put my
my notes but into talking in my head you
know it's as simple a business idea it's
not complex it's not like oh my gosh
there's just crazy complex I could do
this and this usually it's really simple
yeah so I have a lot of business ideas
but then at the same time I think if you
start a business you're a responsibility
to those staff to those customers to
those to then really follow through yeah
so I think it's it's it's it's it's
almost like a marriage almost every time
you set up a business it's a commitment
so not maybe not quite as serious as a
marriage but it's still a commitment so
I think sometimes sometimes knowing and
even as a philanthropist someone if you
get what you know going out and and
deciding how you're gonna best give or
being entrepreneur the hardest thing is
sometimes who not to give to what
business ideas not to start yeah because
kids because you know you can't do
everything kind of everybody can do
everything you can't help everyone you
can't set up every business idea you
have but what you can do is you can def
they keep keeping their it yeah what's
like the biggest hurdle you faced do you
think in what in your inverse five years
while you've been setting up the
business ooh the biggest what is there
anything that you've over the past five
years kind of you've got to that problem
and you have not thought about stopping
but you've maybe it's been something
that's kind of been going around your
head you found hard to kind of overcome
whether that's even just like anything
from my employing people and trying to
find the right people or I can't say
over the last five years haven't felt
like Queen uh I don't even I think I
think maybe the word heard orders didn't
trigger with me because because for me
biggest problem are but my hope my whole
life is firefighting so I've heard also
I guess you could say every every
everyday so the biggest one are I
wouldn't really be able to pinpoint I
wouldn't because it's just for me it's
just it's just a case of alright that's
my job
to overcome to find solutions for
problems so the biggest problem the
biggest hurdle the biggest challenge I
mean I really I really I really I really
don't know yeah because I remember if
you don't mind because I remember the
picture that you shared on Instagram the
other day of you in London because I
remember you saying you're a really low
point there yeah that was massive but I
think ok ok maybe if we go back quite
that far I don't think I might been just
a bit more than five years maybe was
yeah that was a really bad point in my
life
in fact I did feel like quitting that
then but yeah that was a really really
really bad point I think it was a case
of just I mean jeez you really put me on
the spot now yeah I had a relationship
breakdown
and I was had money money taken from me
and I had friends turn their back on
their and it was really that was just
after I finished Bible College and it
was just that was before I even sell my
training business I wasn't running
property training all I had a Christian
Business Network that I was starting up
but yeah that was a really really really
rough rough time yeah and what did you
can you remember what you kind of did to
get yourself out of that mindset and get
you back focused on your business I
think I just I just I just had to just
keep going just about how I felt but I'm
really for a few months I really didn't
feel like it and but uh automatically
people you know my I can't just stop
I've got property deals going through
I've got tenants yeah I've got investors
that I've got deals and stuff going on I
got commitments so I hunt it's like I'm
not gonna just stop and quit or am I
gonna carry on really passionately in
aggressively yeah I'm on either I'm just
gonna give it 20% I'm just gonna slowly
dawdle along and do the bare minimum
whilst in my evenings and weekends
wallowing in my own self-pity for three
months but I know that at some point
I'll get out of it but I'm not gonna
quit you know so that was that was yeah
thanks reminding me would you say
friendships people people sorry to just
just to really say was it was that was
that was just the biggest the biggest
the biggest hurdle that I guess you
could say okay you've coaxed out my
here's the biggest hurdle having people
that you really feel
a ride-or-die forever and people whether
that be in business or or even in my
case it was lots of people at that time
like a swarm the people that were
closest to me just suddenly turn their
back on me and I'm like you know that
and that still happens that still
happens today with some people that I'm
like I thought we were like I thought we
had something really strong I thought
that yeah and it's just you know that
that's hard yeah do you find it hard
like having and making new friends as
someone who's so successful
likes a lot of people want to be around
some of your leads want to be coached by
some your leads and mentored do you kind
of find like you don't know whether
people's heads are in it for the right
reason or what you're gonna yeah because
a lot of the time everything's
everything's business transactional you
know so people are are man let's do some
I'd love to take you for dinner or you
know in this light do you want something
from me do you want to learn something
get something pitch something I think if
I knew them from school yeah I know I
know I know that they're good if it's
like look man I grew up with this person
or if they're also successful of running
businesses doing similar things they're
probably good but it is yeah it's hard
yeah it's hard you Todd man he's genuine
my best friends believe it or not almost
success students are people that are
trained to be financially free now
they're financially free and they just
want to hang around let me say it's like
a family and it literally it's hard
because when you say that it's like a
family well what is a family and what's
like a family and what it's oh it's you
sometimes have to be careful with
language but yeah the people that I've
trained you were successful a lot of
them are like family you know we hang
out and I know know that their you know
their heart is good and I've taken
people heart rips in Africa and we've
done stuff so but some people are very
people are complex yeah I always loved
the story of how you and Amanda ended up
together
yeah and how like you said like you knew
that she was the one when you told her
that you had loads of dirt yeah tell her
about mine okay cuz when I'm a man who
was just after that really low point and
I had money taken from me and I wasn't
running any training so you did wasn't
in YouTube videos
I wasn't known as like the property guru
or anything like that I had lots of
properties but I was living a reasonably
humble Y lifestyle living in like a -
bad house so yeah when I met Amanda we
didn't have any mutual friends because
we met our wedding and we just happened
we don't have any mutual friends and I
didn't tell her about my property
business we just got to know each of
those people so we just chat
life and feelings and just which is
absolutely everything apart from money
and business and we didn't speak about
that and yeah you're right then when I
wanted to propose to her before I
proposed to I told I've not been 100%
honest with my finances she was like
what's up but I told her I've actually
got a million pounds worth of debt which
of course is true because my mortgage is
probably a lot more and and she was just
like okay well you know drop me to see
if I'll get some overtime what's the
plan
I totally owned it was in it no you know
not not like oh my gosh wow that's a big
problem and then I just realized how
unmaterialistic she was and unbothered
about money and success and finance and
of course the success is important to me
but I think that just showed me that she
it was just about us it wasn't about
what I've got about me yeah and then I
told her the flip side which is actually
I have got my husband's debt but I've
also got a lot of equity and we've got
really good cash flow and actually yeah
and actually and she was she was just uh
she said that's good then I was like
uh-huh yep it is good and then I
proposed and then we got married within
months and lived happily ever after such
a nice story
thank you and do you have any advice for
people that Excel I see people comment
and how do you you know get around
successful people how do you get around
people with good mindsets good
intentions do you have any advice for do
it yourself do it yourself if you want a
really fit girlfriend that works at the
gym has got a six-pack and is clean and
positive if that's the kind of
girlfriends you want don't be an idiot
and write down this is the person that I
want I'm gonna find that person
right now the person that you want to
become yeah so write down your own list
this is who I want to become I want to
be ripped I want to be positive I want
to be all the things that you want to
become and then what will happen is then
you'll attract that person you know
track those people so if you want to
hang around people that are successful
you need to become successful if you
want to hang around people that are
action takers and go-getters and
high-energy
you've got to be an action taker in high
energy and then
yeah because no one's gonna want to hang
around remove your fat lose ooh you
won't take risks and who has got no
energy no one who's got energy and takes
risks and loves that law I know I'm
gonna want to hang around you what would
they cuz then because because bad
company corrupts good character they'll
see your bad company and there were an
over a mile so just be the kind of
person you want to be around and the
reason I get to hang around really
successful people have dinners with
amazing you know celebrities and have
people on my youtube channel who are
just killing it and have fun and have
get invested all these pies you've great
people which I do get is because that's
who I am yeah you know I'm not I'm not
saying I'm better than anyone or
anyone's better than anyone but it's not
about who's better or worse as a person
who's got a high value as a human being
it's just about like attracts like so if
you want a particular kind of person to
hang around you know if you want to hang
around people who are wealthy or
successful or positive then just be that
yourself and it will happen and make an
effort make an effort for it to happen
attend the network groups there I go to
the Condor places stalk them maybe is
anyone you really would love to me in a
minute I would love to get mentored by
here would I love to me at the minute
I'd love to spend some time with Tony
Robbins I've I've seen him speak on
stage I've never met him I think he's a
super cool guy and I think I could learn
a lot from him watched his documentary
yes yes I think it's great he's a great
guy and he's one of the few people that
I really like do really well and and
also coaches and teachers that like that
in that niche who I haven't spent time
with so Tony man if you can hear this
I'm coming for you bro yeah well send it
over to now do it yeah thank you for
talking to me today in Turners about
entrepreneurship and thank you all for
listening as well and we'll be back next
week with another episode
[Music]
[Music]
you